also können davon ausgehen dass in
zukunft für die mobile version von
minecraft von kappel hinzugefügt wird
und das ja schon mal eine ganz
interessante sache
hallöchen freunden herzlich willkommen
hier zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft facts am dienstag ich freue
mich dass wieder mit dabei sein ich
würde mich freuen wenn du bis zum ende
dran bleibt und wenn ihr einen weg bist
dann nicht ins formular schreiben weil
da sind 33.000 facts und da habe ich
überhaupt keinen überblick mehr und da
ist auch begrenzte zahlenangabe bis
gesehen ich mache das jetzt neuerdings
unternehmen die einfach in die
kommentare schreiben können weil dann
kann man auch untereinander diskutieren
ob eventuell falsch ist oder richtig
oder ob der gut ich unternehme und dann
würde ich sagen fangen wir jetzt einfach
an mit fake nummer und zwar schreibt mit
der mmm lkh de luca weiß nicht ob das
als pack zählt wenn man einen brauch
stand im kreativ abbaut sieht man in der
abbau animation einen dunkelroten trank
sondern auch so ganz viele blöde ps der
1000 rechtschreibfehler drin ich habe
hier einfach mal einen raus stand und
ihr seht schon da ist nix drin da ist
kein trank oder irgendwie sonst was
deswegen habe ich den jetzt einfach mal
kaputt und wenn ihr euch das jetzt mal
genau anschaut
seht ihr da kommt so ein kleines rotes
partikelchen augen mal ganz genau
hinschaut dieser brauch stand hat keinen
trank drin und der ist an den seiten
auch nicht rot sondern er hat seine so
schwartze halterung hier und das ziehen
damit es auch ja umsonst als irgendwann
roth aber ich versuche ich jetzt mal
davon screenshot einzublenden einfach
mal pausieren und zwar so ihr seht ihr
den spinnern eingeblendet da seht ihr
die partikel wie von sonnen wie von
seinem roten färbung style von diesem
rosenrot oder was man aus diesen rosen
gewinnen kann diese flieger farbstoff
deswegen verstehe ich nicht ganz genau
warum das ein roter partikel auf doch
das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich wie mit
diesem hohen gras also das hatte ich ja
schon mal wenn ein hohes gras zerstört
das dann kurzzeitig sonnenblume
angezeigt wird aber sonst wie ich sagen
ist ein ganz simpler fact und perfekt
nummer 1 und nummer 2 wurde mir
zugesendet von zog rlp conny ich hätte
mal einen weg für dich wenn man einen
mob in minecraft heute bekommt man ja
items und wenn man plünderung auf sein
schwert gibt bekommt man ja meistens
aber mir ist aufgefallen dass wenn man
plünderung auf seinem schwert hat und
ein schaf töten bekommt man trotzdem nur
eine rolle
puh ich habe hier das komplette
equipment am start ich packte aber in
diamant stadt rain und ein verzaubertes
buch mit windows
drei verzauberte das und sporne jetzt
hier einen scharf und töte das ist mal
mit meinem diamant schwert und ihr seht
schon
ich bekomme nur eine wolle das ganze
jetzt nochmal mit vier weiteren schaffen
machen und ich werde euch versprechen
dass ich am ende einfach nur fünf voll
im inventar hat soll jetzt hab ich
nämlich schon 3 jetzt habe ich 4
und jetzt habe ich fünf natürlich
bekomme ich extrem viel rohes
hammelfleisch einfach von den schafen
weil das ja plünderung ist und dadurch
bekommt mehr items das fokussiert sich
auch auf alle sachen also wenn ich einen
zombie tötet dass ich dann mehr zombie
gehirne bekomme oder wenn ich einen weiß
ich nicht ein krieg bedeute das nicht
mehr ganz oder bekommen irgendwie und
bezieht sich auf alles oder halten mehr
fleisch bei schafen aber es bezieht sich
nicht auf die rolle und das finde ich
eigentlich müssen traurig weil man kann
halt wolle wirklich und das hat mein
kräftig so vorgeschrieben nur mit einer
schere bekommt man mehr wolle
das heißt ich weiß nicht was das soll
das plünderung dabei das nicht bringt
aber man muss sich dann wurde ich eine
schere machen also denkt nicht dass wir
miteinander mehr wolle bekommt aber das
war auf jeden fall fake nummer 200 wurde
mit zugewinnen von zocker lp dann kann
dich so freunde der nächste weg wurde
mir zugesendet von e.on player hd und
verschleppte hey conny habe zwei fix für
dich den ersten habe ich allerdings
schon mal vorgestellt deswegen werde ich
nur den zweiten dran nehmen und zwar
wenn du einen ender christoph sports und
dann von einem mob zb einem zombie
angegriffen wirst und den ender christel
kaputt aus steht im chat konkreter wurde
von zombie in die luft gesprengt das ist
ein bisschen paradox und zwar die sonne
geht gerade auf aber ich wollte jetzt
mal erst mal ein ende christin kann ich
nämlich so spohn und jetzt bin ich hier
auch einen zombie und setzt sich selber
in den game zu null also der zombie
greift mich jetzt an dass sie schon und
ich zerstöre den ender christel und dann
steht im chat konkreter wurde durch
zombie in die luft gesprengt das ist ein
bisschen komisch weil ein zombie kamin
in die luft sprengen eigentlich wurde
ich vom ende christa getötet aber er
denkt quasi dieses minecraft spiel ruhig
wurde zuletzt von einem zombie
attackiert und bin gestorben aber ich
bin eigentlich die luft gesprengt worden
also verbinde ich die beiden sachen
einfach ein bisschen komisch aber das
auf jeden fall fällt nummer 3 der mit
zugesendet wurde von e.on player hd auf
fake nummer vier hat mich ein kommentar
des nutzers companies gebracht und zwar
der etwas über entities geschrieben und
dann habe ich einfach mal so ein
bisschen herumprobiert mit ntt sind
bilder auf eine ganz eigene
interessante sache geschossen und zwar
normalerweise nicht geschafft jetzt
einfach mal ein schwein und wie ist es
wenn ich auf 3 und b drücke werden die
hit boxen aktiv das habe ich ja schon
mal vorgestellt und dann zeigt dass
dieses blaue ding hier quasi wo dieser
dieser mob hin zeigt das heißt wenn ich
das schwein des beispiels mal schlage
seht ihr dieses blaue ding zeigt immer
genau in die richtung oder schwein
hinläuft schaut es beispielsweise zu mir
es geht dass da so ein bisschen in die
richtung geht das bis nach oben und so
kommt darauf an wo das schwein hinschaut
wenn ich allerdings war in rüstung
ständer hierhin schau der auch ein
entity ist schaut er jetzt von dem
blauen teilen die richtung wenn ich von
hier hinstelle schaut es ebenfalls in
die richtung welche das theoretisch auch
mal so schräg hinstelle und es
eigentlich ihr hinschauen müsste schaut
es immer noch in die richtung genau das
gleiche mit irgendwelchen wenn ich hier
beispielsweise mal hier einen sand
gesetzt und hier ein kies und ich hab
den sandberger von vorlegen gesetzt den
kiez von hinten hin und zerschlagen die
beiden sachen die werden ja dann während
des falls zu entities die schauen
trotzdem alle in die gleiche richtung
das ist eine extrem interessante sache
weil ich verstehe es einfach nicht dass
die werden ja als entities angesehen und
eigentlich müsste dann in die blaue
richtung dieser blaue fall seien die
richtung sein wo die hinschauen aber es
ist egal von wo ich die hinsetze das
blaue ding zeigt immer in richtung süden
genauso wie bei mir das hier ist das
zeigt in richtung süden aber bei den
entities die sich richtig bewegen also
mops et cetera oder da den tintenfischen
oder so zeigt es wenn man die richtung
wo sie hinschauen wirklich und guckt man
jetzt hier habe ich dir hier hingelegt
und jetzt jetzt schon die auch wieder
das ist eine ganz komische sache mit
diesem blauen teilen das hat mir der
complus zugesendet und zwar der mir
eigentlich effekt zugesendet das
entities während des falls also blöcke
während des falls zu entities werden
wenn sie in ein lava sie fallen und
brennen aber den fall jetzt ein bisschen
unspektakulär deswegen habe ich das
einfach so ein bisschen erweitert und es
perfekt 045 defekt wurde mir zugesendet
voneinander lp hier wird nicht so
kreativ mit den namen ändern jedenfalls
steuerfahnder lw ihr einfällt in der
minecraft b version soll ein paddel
hinzugefügt werden hier ein nachweis und
schreibt er da den nachweis hin und ihr
seht ihr mal den nachweis eingeblendet
wie jetzt gerade schon den twitter chat
verlauf eingeblendet zwischen tom das
ist so ein mitarbeiter von mojang für
die mobile version und schauen das ist
ein ganz normaler typ beschreibt der tom
einfach ja die schaufel wird für
die mobile version noch ganz interessant
werden also die wird noch ganz wichtig
und dann schreibt ein nutzer hh wird das
denn das crafting rezept genauso sein
wie für die boote oder oder wie wird das
sein oder mit der textur und so wenn die
einmal fertig sind und dann schreibt der
turm allerdings wieder ja das wird
wahrscheinlich zu fünf baumstämme
brauchen fünf normale banks also fünf so
diese diese schon verarbeiteten
baumstämme und ein paddel item also dass
man dann das boot quasi ein ganz
wichtiges item noch wird und dass man
mit seiner schaufel ähnlichen sache dann
einfach paddeln kann also wir können
davon ausgehen dass in zukunft für die
mobile version von minecraft zum paddel
hinzugefügt wird und das ja schon mal
eine ganz interessante sache damit würde
ich sagen meine lieben freunde was für
diese folge der minecraft dienstag ich
würde da würde ich mich überall
ich würde mich über eine bewertung
freuen und wir sehen uns dann morgen in
dem video wieder oder übermorgen und
dann sehen wir uns dort wieder 15
kommentare schreiben